that's what we did we laughed we left
all the time so much yeah like that was
so much a part of our connection was
that we love funny people yeah we enjoy
laughing at all times i
love that we've maintained our love
because it i i don't think it'll ever i
know from my end it'll never go anywhere
i'll love you always you know and so i i
i'm glad that we're able to
still have that i mean that i i always
love you
i i will always love you so much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i feel like we've been through so much
together too you know i feel like when
we used to like talk and facetime i was
always like you know i've really grown
up justin like i always wanted to prove
to you
what a different person i was than when
we dated you were the best we had so
much it's fun no i know it was it too
but we were you know
more hedonistic
more
immature you know we would get together
we would break up you know there was
chaos it was hell of fun fun chaos oh
yeah yeah well it's yeah most hedonism
is fun there's not a lot of bad heat in
this room
you